crews in louisiana are working almost
non-stop to clear the damage from
hurricane laura
four days after the storm hit more than
300
000 homes and businesses still have no
power
laura is blamed for at least 18 deaths
in louisiana
louisiana and texas it was one of the
strongest hurricanes ever to make
landfall on the gulf coast
omar villafranca is in hard hit lake
charles louisiana omar what are you
seeing there now
well good morning hurricane laura
destroyed this building and the only
reason that you're able to see it
because we're using generators to use
our lights
to light it up because all of the power
in lake charles and calcushu
parish is out and despite an army of
line crews working nonstop we're seeing
some pass by right now
it could take weeks possibly even months
before power
is restored after hurricane laura
for southwestern louisiana removing
downed trees and debris
is just the beginning of the cleanup
hurricane lora's 150 mile per hour winds
knocked down thousands of utility poles
people here are now facing 90 degree
temperatures and high humidity
with no electricity or running water
it's
terrible it's catastrophic nick hunter
is the mayor of lake charles
have you heard any estimates of when
you're going to get power back
weeks 100 of the cities without power
right now
i would say definitely over a month in
many parts of lake charles
over the weekend president trump toured
some of the damage
the storm made roads impassable and
ripped roofs off buildings
leaving some people scrambling to put up
tarps as scattered showers moved in
in many cases homes were wiped out
there's a lot of our citizens that are
absolutely homeless and i don't mean
that in a dramatic sense or
some type of trumped up adjective and
they need places to stay
and preferably right now those places
need to be outside of lake charles
it's me coming back soon on saturday 19
seniors some in need of medical care
were found in dire conditions at an
apartment complex in lake charles
where they say they felt abandoned it's
hot it's muggy
senior citizens are overheating they
have no power they haven't showered in
days they have no running water
volunteers with matthew marchetti's
organization crowd source rescue
drove them to a shelter in new orleans
it is our
solemn duty if we can help we should
we reached out to the lake charles
housing authority for a comment about
those seniors but did not hear back
another issue that's complicating the
recovery here is the coronavirus
pandemic people need a social distance
there's 16 000 people who are staying in
hotel rooms
but less than a thousand who are staying
in those old school
giant places for people to recover tony
amazing to hear the mayor of lake
charles telling people to stay away omar
via franco force continuing our coverage
of hurricane laura omar thank you very
much